les français parlent aux français d
échange dans le respect au forum
armand peugeot à poissy la première
soirée organisée par la commune dans le
cadre du grand débat national
pendant trois heures une centaine de
citoyens à échanger sur les institutions
les finances publiques et sur des
thématiques libre l'ensemble des
pisciacais et des pisciacais les
habitants de poissy veulent s'exprimer
et ils veulent s'exprimer comme ils
s'expriment dans le cadre du quotidien
avec les collègues élus que nous sommes
ici à pau si ils veulent de l'expression
directe ils veulent pas forcément des
thèmes imposés
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité qu'ils
aient des thèmes libres également et on
l'a vu ce soir
on peut ne pas être d'accord des
désaccords notamment sur l'allongement
de l'âge du départ à la retraite mais
aussi des convergences sur la volonté de
transparence et de participation des
citoyens dans les décisions politiques
j'ai vu des gens passionnés par la
politique et moi ça fait 15 ans que je
vote c'est la première fois que je vois
autant de gens qui sont intéressés pas à
petit ça me donne de l'espoir de voir
les gens s'impliquent est autant
évaluation des réformes renforcer la
décentralisation ou supprimer le cic e
pour les grandes entreprises
de nombreuses propositions émises durant
la soirée les élus par rapport à leurs
concitoyens qui n'est pas de verticalité
comme ça a été dit et donc qu'ils
puissent avoir un échange entre
associations et élus pour l'intérêt
général celui que j'avais un souci avec
le mécanisme d'impôt sur le revenu tel
qu'elles ajustent actuellement lorsque
je pense qu'il est totalement injuste
incompréhensible qui devrait être mis à
plat complètement pour être beaucoup
plus citoyen est beaucoup plus
égalitaire
de mon point de vue il n'y absolument
aucune différence entre un euro que vous
percevez à travers un salaire ou une
pension est un héros pur sever travers
une subvention ou une prime qui vient de
l'état donc je pense mais 2 devrait être
fiscalisés prochain rendez vous mardi 5
février au théâtre de poissy avec au
programme la transition écologique et
l'organisation de l'état